З 1 січня в Україні запрацювала монетизація субсидій, тобто видача їх у вигляді "живих" грошей.
На це в держбюджеті на цей рік передбачено 20 мільярдів гривень.
Розмір субсидії у грошовому еквіваленті
надходитиме отримувачу на його персональний рахунок у банку.
Цей рахунок автоматично відкриють в Ощадбанку
після відповідної заяви отримувача субсидії на монетизацію.
Додатково звертатися в банк не потрібно.
Ці кошти можна буде витратити лише на оплату комуналки.
Банк розраховуватиметься за платника з надавачами комунальних послуг
та через смс інформуватиме про те, скільки ще залишилося доплатити за комуналку.
Відстежити усі перерахунки користувач зможе онлайн.
Якщо кошти на комуналку вдасться зекономити,
то після завершення опалювального сезону
отримувач субсидії зможе витратити їх на власний розсуд.
Цей банк є уповноваженою державою фінансовою установою - не лише у цій, а й у низці інших програм.
Банк володіє найбільшою мережею відділень - більше трьох тисяч.
А також має великий досвід виплат соціальної допомоги та пенсій.
Комісії Ощадбанку отримувачі субсидій платити не будуть.
Субсидію отримують майже половина українських родин.
Якщо роздати всім гроші на руки,
є ризик що люди почнуть витрачати гроші на власний розсуд, а не на комуналку.
Це лише збільшить комунальні борги населення та може призвести до гіперінфляції,
пояснюють у Міністерстві соціальної політики.
З 1 січня "живі" гроші виплачуватимуть тим, хто звернеться по допомогу вперше.
З 1 травня монетизація торкнеться і тих, хто користувався субсидіями і раніше.
А з 1 жовтня на нову форму отримання державної допомоги переведуть усіх отримувачів субсидій.
Отримати "монетизовані" субсидії зможуть ті,
хто витрачає на комунальні послуги понад 15% щомісячного сукупного доходу.
Рахуватимуть за доходом зареєстрованих у будинку осіб.
Якщо житло орендоване, то оформити субсидію можна на підставі договору найму чи оренди.
Усім отримувачам пільг і субсидій потрібно заповнити заяву і декларацію про доходи.
Перевірка доходів та матеріального становища тих, хто претендує на субсидії,
буде жорсткішою та прискіпливішою.
Наприклад, відтепер субсидії не зможуть отримувати родини,
в яких є автомобіль віком менше п’яти років,
власники квартир площею більше ста двадцяти квадратних метрів
та будинків у понад двісті квадратних метрів, особи, які є фіктивно безробітними,
тобто ті, які працюють, офіційно не оформлюючись, або ж працюють за кордоном.
Нині, за даними уряду, комунальні субсидії отримують
понад шістдесят відсотків домогосподарств.
У 2017 на це пішло більше шістдесяти мільярдів гривень бюджетних коштів.
Уряд очікує, що із запровадженням нової системи зловживань із субсидіями стане менше.